so let's turn to the Epistle itself a
little bit and talk in this session
about chapters 1 2 3 tell us about how
the Epistle starts and what's at stake
for Paul as he introduces himself and
his gospel to these Romans right as
always in Paul's epistles he begins with
a salutation and this is the standard
form of letter writing in antiquity Paul
develops a little bit more than you'd
find in private letters that which we
have in abundance from my right right
but it's basically the same form that as
the sender says that he's sending
greetings to the recipients and
identifies who those recipients are and
then expands on that a little bit and so
Paul's expansion of that salutation
tells us something about his concerns in
the first couple of verses of Romans
Christ is at the center of all of this
the gospel about Christ right at which
he talks about in verses 3 & 4 the
gospel concerning his son son of God who
was descended from David according to
the flesh and was declared to be son of
God with power according to the spirit
of holiness by the resurrection from the
dead
so Christ's status as the Son of God
manifested in his resurrection yeah is
something that's central to what Paul
wants to talk about is the David David
versus resurrection thing is that a way
of saying both for Jews and for Gentiles
does the son of David claim his
Jewishness and the rest claim his
Gentile application to it that's an
interesting way of thing about certainly
the allusion to David is an appeal to
the Jewish tradition right and one of
the things that Paul wants to insist on
is that despite the discontinuities in
salvation history there's an important
strand of continuity right and
Christianity is rooted in its Jewish
sources in a significant way so the
allusion to David I think is part of
that that general claim in any case Paul
goes on says a little bit about himself
and his Apostleship so that was a major
issue and some of us earlier
correspondence it's not an issue here
but it's something that he wants to
appeal as part of his relationship with
this community and then the next the
next phase of the letter a standard part
of any ancient letter is a little prayer
of thanksgiving and almost all of
Paul's letters have a section like this
Paul off is a bit of thanks or praise to
God for something and usually what he's
thanking people for is something that he
has on his mind exactly right that's
going to be part right letter
so the Thanksgiving begins in verse
eight first I give
I thank my God through Jesus Christ for
all of you because your faith is
proclaimed throughout the world and one
of the key things that Paul is going to
be arguing is that the relationship
between God's people and God is now
based on faith not based on ethnic
derivation or the law of the instant all
right
so the faith of the Romans that he is
not responsible for is something that he
wants to celebrate and wants to argue
about a little bit later on and so he
continues then and talks about his
longing to be part of the community
community of Rome and to have damned
supporting his mission as we'll hear at
the end of writer and he he mentions all
of this mentions the way in which he's
related to two Gentiles as well as to
introduce whatever they composition at
the Roman community might be and then
finally in verses 16 and 17 he gives us
I think what is what's almost a thesis
statement about the letter and one thing
about Romans is that it it is it is
structured as as something of an
argument is there's a connectedness to
the letter that we don't have in some of
other Paul's some other of Paul's
letters where the discrete problems are
taken up Allison sitting up correctly
one by one yeah so the thesis statement
for I am not ashamed of the gospel it is
the power of God for salvation to
everyone who has faith here that theme
of faith to the Jew first and also to
the Greek
so the relationship between Jew and
Greek point of tension as you indicated
there possibly at work in Rome is
something that he wants to address here
for in it the righteousness of God is
revealed through faith for faith so that
the prose it gets to be celebratory here
in a little bit okay it does but we know
that Paul is celebrating the action of
God he sees taking place in Christ and
in his own apostolate and it's an action
that works somehow through faith it's
almost as if 17 could be the
righteousness of God
revealed through God's faithfulness for
the faith of believers I think that
against the two-sided nose of it in our
way
that's right and it's interesting to
think about just a little bit with this
term faith means we're going to have to
be coming back at that especially in
Romans 4 and that it's inappropriate I
think to think of it in simply cognitive
auditor absolutely as a form of belief
yep although there are cognitive
dimensions to it it does involve
fidelity it does involve an act of the
heart and the will as well as the trust
and it is it goes both ways
God is faithful God's promises and
people respond as Jesus responded as the
faithful one that's right so Paul at the
beginning of Romans 1 then sort of sets
the tone for the whole letter and sounds
some themes that are going to be really
important and then what he does in the
next two chapters is I think in broad
terms to set set out the problem that
the righteousness of God was designed to
solve okay
so he reflects here in a way he has not
done and some of his other epistles
almost globally sketching the the human
condition and the way in which God has
somehow addressed that human condition
and what he the heart of the argument is
that sin is a reality that pervades the
human condition whether Universal
universe oh except shion's whether
you're a Gentile or whether you are a
Jew there is there is sin in your
experience right and God through Christ
has somehow addressed that problem of
sin yeah so that's the overall structure
here I don't know about you but you do
you find it sometimes hard to follow
Paul's arguments and I do I do I
sometimes have a hard time he sometimes
seems to be responding to somebody we
don't meet on the scene and it's not
clear that the arguments just come from
his own mind he he imagines it he
imagines interlocutors to whom he
responds and I bet always puzzles me
right in this passage particularly yeah
for instance at the beginning of chapter
2 therefore you have no excuse you right
yeah right yeah this is something that
we find in
certain kinds of philosophical
literature and antiquity usually called
the diatribe and it's a form of
scholastic discourse people like
Epictetus in the first century a Greek
philosopher uses this form pretty widely
people have recognized this for a good
long time and have recognized that one
of the things that you have to unpack in
in Paul is the way in which he uses
these imaginary imaginary interlocutors
at times yeah to move the argument here
on so I think one of the the things that
we need to to hear here especially in
the latter part of chapter one is
another person's voice okay the the
voice perhaps of a Gentile philosophers
but identified in different ways Gentile
philosopher or a Jew preaching to
Gentiles yeah if the latter works pretty
well I think pretty well and then Paul
sort of speaks in the persona of that
that individual and the sort of turns
the tables on he came back to himself
yeah yeah yeah you could see that again
in verse 17 of chapter 2 but if you call
yourself a Jew right who's the you yeah
do you is some sort of imaginary Jewish
interlocutor who at that point has
probably been condemning Gentiles and
what Paul wants to say is yeah I endorse
what Jews have said about the sinfulness
of Gentiles but I also want to point out
to both Jew and Gentile that people who
are making those condemnatory remarks of
themselves interest really in fact are
sinful in part because they're making
them yeah yeah yeah so it's a kind of
clever dialogical scheme that Paul has
working here and yet you have to be
attentive to the different voices that
that Paul was using so where does he go
in trying to solve the problem he sets
up he says everybody is sinned mm-hmm
then what what's what's the beginning of
a solution anyway the beginning of the
solution Paul sketches at the end of
chapter three and this has caused all
sorts of theological reflection from
chapter 3 verse 21 on it Paul says but
now irrespective of law and the role of
law the role of
Tora or something that's going to be on
Paul's mind throughout irrespective of
law the righteousness of God has been
disclosed attested by the law on the
profits he's just used scriptural
quotations they're hugely to show that
everybody is sinful right the
righteousness of God through faith in
Jesus Christ that for all who believe
that note by the way they phrase faith
in Jesus Christ there's a translation
issue here that goes back to what we
were talking about about faith and
fidelity and a lot of scholars now think
it's more proper to translate this and
analogous phrases as the faith of Jesus
Christ the fidelity and commitment that
Jesus himself exemplified is that which
we imitate your incoming part of his
community and I think that's probably
right in any case God has done something
with the righteousness of God acting
through the fidelity of Christ which has
a beneficial impact on all who follow
Christ and and fidelity all who believe
and Paul emphasizes the impartiality of
God and the universality of the message
there's no distinction all have sinned
and fallen short of the glory god this
is verse 23 but are now justified by His
grace as a gift you know so God the
fundamental point that Paul says is that
God has taken action to deal with this
problem of universal sin and it's a an
act of pure grace yeah gift a gift gift
not on the cheap that's right yeah a
gift that Paul that God has given to
humankind
somehow connected with the death of
Christ yeah and that's indicated in
verse 25 whom God put forward as and
here another translation problem put
forward as a sacrifice of atonement by
his blood that maybe it's certainly one
way of translating it and maybe Paul's
notion that Christ was in some ways a
sacrificial offering of Beccaria
sufferer evoking the servant songs of
isaiah that may be lurking in the
background it may be that he alludes
here using an celtic language to the the
seat of mercy
in the Holy of Holies very temple the
locus of God's gracious air whatever
yeah it doesn't matter for our purposes
the theological tradition has worried an
awful lot about how that works
Paul doesn't worry about how it works he
just says God has taken care of it yeah
and what we have to do is accept God's
gracious gift okay well and then with
for Ron we begin to see what that might
look like in our lives right absolutely
maybe before we conclude we ought to
think about some of the little
difficulties that pop up in as far as
couple of chapters what what do you do
for instance with some of this the sins
that Paul well I think that the you set
the context right the context is that
Paul wants to implicate everyone in sin
it's fairly clear how you do that with
Jews they disobey the law Gentiles seem
not to have the law how can you blame
Gentiles and his prime example of
Gentiles it is idolatry and that leads
into the complicated material about
human sexuality in Chapter one and what
I say about that is within his context
idolatry is great concerned sexuality is
a secondary concern it's certainly one
that's driven the discussion in our
churches for the past twenty five or
thirty years
yeah those verses are Romans 1:26 and
following yeah and you're absolutely
right man they the fundamental problem
is idolatry and then Paul says that is
the source of everything else that's
wrong with which the humankind very long
grocery list yeah and he mentions in
here same-sex relationships of area
sorts picking up on themes from
Leviticus exactly which is not a concern
to him post up right right right
suddenly he needs it yeah and I think
one of the things we have to keep in
mind here is that this this section
Romans 1:18 through the end of that
chapter is really kind of boilerplate
yes absolutely it's sort of Google's sin
something like that this is what your
standard Jewish preacher would be saying
in talking to Gentiles about why they
should have to give up their lifestyle
and become Jewish yeah I'm not sure Paul
has given an awful lot of thought to
that and he certainly hasn't given
thought to human sexuality in a way and
the way we come to understand it
yeah I sometimes tell congregations that
asking what Paul thought about
homosexuality is we think about it is
like asking what he thinks about
evolution and that our world of thought
is he didn't have it we he didn't think
about those things the way we do right
so in any case idolatry certainly is one
of the main things that he talks about
some other interesting features here is
is that he insists that people are going
to be judged on the basis of what they
do yeah and sometimes when we we hear of
Paul's gospel of justification by faith
we forget that there's also an element
of federal responsibility and we're
going to hear that theme hugely yeah
Romans you thank you